every year the battle between Microsoft
and Apple gets more and more intense
this year let's see who came out on top
what's going on guys my name is David
homage and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here smash that subscribe
button and join us as we talk all things
tech today we're looking at the
Microsoft Surface laptop 3 and we're
looking at the 2019
MacBook Pro more specifically we're
going to be looking at the intro model
of both of these devices as they're the
best selling devices for each brand
let's start with some big-ticket items
the price the Microsoft Surface laptop 3
in Australia starts with 1357 or 933 USD
whilst the MacBook Pro starts from 1999
Australian or 1375 USD you can get 10%
off both of these devices if you're a
university student so that's definitely
something to keep in mind so the first
point for the price category goes to
Microsoft tech specs for the base
surface laptop 3 you get a 10th
generation eye 5 Intel Core chip 8
gigabytes of RAM and 128 gigabytes of
SSD storage whilst in the MacBook Pro
you get an eighth-generation eye 5 intel
core processor with also 8 gigabytes of
RAM and 128 gigabytes of SSD storage so
on paper when you're comparing these two
base level specs you find that the
Microsoft gains an additional point here
but when you stop looking at the paper
figures and you actually start looking
at the device you find that the ports
become a very big problem on the
Microsoft Surface laptop 3 you get a USB
a a USB C a headphone jack and also a
proprietary fast charging connector
whilst on the MacBook Pro you get four
USB C ports with two of those ports
being Thunderbolt 3 you don't get any
Thunderbolts on the Microsoft Surface
laptop 3 so if you look at these two
devices at the surface laptop 3 probably
more compatible ports for this day and
age you're not going to need any
adapters to use any of your old devices
or any of your new devices going forward
but in a couple years time you probably
will need to convert that single USB a
to a USB C to run all your latest tech
whilst Apple on the other hand has given
you advantage of going for all four USB
C ports this might not be a great
advantage to start because you may have
to grab a couple of adapters or
alternatively go out and buy all new
tech that's USB C compatible but in the
future you're definitely going to be
better off as we all know Apple has
always been the leaders in port
technology when it comes to tech a few
years ago you may remember that they
released the iPhone 7 with no headphone
jack this caused a lot of commotion and
everybody was up in arms however if you
think about it two years later every
single flagship device manufacturer
including Samsung themselves has quickly
removed all headphone jacks this is more
for a money kind of financial system
because they're able to create more
revenue from selling you their wireless
headphones then they were from selling
you some cheap cable headphones in the
past so if we look at this as an example
Apple going with the four USB C port on
the MacBook Pro definitely gives it the
advantage for future proofing and that's
why I'm giving the port's point to Apple
charging and battery life this is a
pretty big category in my opinion
charging is everything I don't really
like charged my devices overnight
especially if I know I need it a couple
hours later and also considering the
fact that laptops are meant to be a
travel device you really want your
devices to be long lasting and quick
charging the surface laptop three
charges from zero to 80% in under one
hour and has a theoretical runtime of
eleven and a half hours which you may or
may not have noticed is significantly
less than the surface laptop two which
had a theoretical runtime of fourteen
and a half hours I know I personally
experienced on my old surface laptop too
that you could get about 16 hours of
runtime off this device which is
significantly more than what
promising in the surfs laptop three
whilst the Apple MacBook Pro has a
theoretical charge time from zero to 80%
in under two hours and a total
theoretical battery runtime of 10.5
hours sorry Apple this is a very great
attempt but the point again goes to
Microsoft moving on to the screen
quality because for me screen quality is
very important you don't want to be
thinking I know I can't see my screen
it's too dark it's not clear it's blurry
especially when you're paying anywhere
between 1300 and 2000 straigh llion
dollars for a laptop this is where the
surface three starts to show some cracks
with 318 it's of brightness 201 pixels
per inch and a 10-point touchscreen
display you'd think this is pretty good
quality how about when you compare it to
the Apple MacBook Pro you find that it's
a very different story the MacBook Pro
has 500 nits of brightness 227 pixels
per inch but no touchscreen display it
does promise 25% more colors than the
srgb range that's inside the Microsoft
Surface laptop 3 and it does offer you
the true tone color display so if you've
ever used one of these Retina screens
you know for a fact that Apple screen is
significantly better than anything that
Microsoft's produced to date so we
currently stand at three points to
Microsoft and two points to Apple
keyboards and trackpads the Microsoft
Surface laptop - already had a fantastic
keyboard that was miles ahead of the
2018 MacBook Pro so when they brought
out the surface laptop 3 you knew they
were gonna make it better the surface
laptop 3s keyboard is just that little
bit quieter just that little bit nicer
and just that little bit better than
anything else on the market nonetheless
the MacBook Pro still does have a very
nice butterfly keyboard with ultra quiet
keys this isn't any disadvantage the
MacBook Pro but in my personal opinion
it isn't as nice to type it isn't as
easy to type and after a while you just
start to get annoyed because your
fingertips hurt because there's no
rebound on the
it's just like tapping aluminium all day
it is rumoured 2020 MacBook Pro will
solve this issue with a brand new
keyboard setup but until it's released
we don't know what Apple's gonna launch
looking at the two trackpads personally
for me they're both really really good I
don't find a fault in either of them
they're both a nice large size with the
MacBooks being slightly bigger and
slightly easy to use but when you
compare them like for like there isn't
too much of a difference in my opinion
so unfortunately for the poor quality of
the keyboard on the MacBook side things
I'm rewarding this point against a
Microsoft ecosystems and compatibility
Microsoft
well what ecosystem it doesn't really
have anything integrated between its
devices the MacBook Pro on the other
hand has this very user-friendly very
inviting Apple experience between its
devices if you have an iPhone and iPad
and a MacBook well your life just got a
hell of a lot easier
unfortunately for Apple it still does
have some compatibility issues when
programs are concerned you can run boot
camp and parallel on it to fix these
problems so that takes away from the con
entirely when we're talking ecosystems
Apple definitely gets the point I could
keep this comparison going on forever if
I'm being honest with you and at the end
of the day both devices would end up
neck-and-neck the surface laptop 3 and
2019 MacBook Pro are both incredible
pieces of tech with their own pros and
cons personally if I was to go out and
buy one of these devices today and only
use one of these devices well it would
be the Microsoft Surface laptop 3 for
the sole purpose of the better keyboard
if the new 20/20 MacBook Pro comes out
with a competitive keyboard that's just
as nice to use as a surface laptop 3 and
also comes it out with a competitive
price tag that isn't 700 Australian
dollars more than the surface laptop 3
then my personal opinion will change and
the crown will go to Apple but for the
time being I personally believe that the
surface laptop 3 comes out on top for
price compatibility and just the general
user experience that's all from me guys
thanks so much for watching if you
enjoyed the video make sure you smash
that subscribe button
20-19 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday